a man raises a child that he believes is
hid and the mother knows that she lied
should she be punishable by law and what
would the punishment be she should be
punished
she should be that's like
that's actually
[Music]
even argue however many years the guy
spent like raising that kid give her a
gift
that's that's it's terrible that's a
terrible thing to do you deserve to be
punished you wasted that man you know
how much do you know how much like
emotion yeah he's putting into that kid
stop you from even having your own yeah
i mean that fear of even going into yeah
to be honest i think it's just the same
as like females lying about uh
it's the exact same for me to be honest
say great youtube
great great great great so
great i like such a sensitive subject
though like yes yeah it's exactly the
same it's all the same right category
because it actually happens and then
that people lie so it's like when it
comes up
people don't don't know whether to like
how to attach it yeah it's always
detrimental to someone's image it's true
imagine i said on your name like
your life changes literally like bro it
happened i don't know
you don't have to say names i'm not
going to say names but obviously okay it
happened last year in it but the one
thing about me is i'm not i'm not i'm
not a biased guy like i always want to
hear two sides of the story long story
short
i did it side no one but i was still
there for the guys so if i found out it
was true i'd be like oh cool i'm gonna
have to back up but everyone else is
like oh rah-rah long story short that
the guy didn't do it so this girl got
everyone against him now everyone was
just there like he boss case he's
chilling but it's like yeah the fact
that that whole time period bro yeah bro
the guy was in his room like
upset sad like he had no one bro i'm
burning around he was the one that
introduced me to everyone so everyone
just left him i was just thinking ah bro
it's one of them ones like if you if you
play sports
how could you even leave your room to
even come yeah with that on your name
like everyone's gonna be looking at you
differently if you have a game there's
gonna be like oh yeah that's the guy
how's he even allowed to play
you go through that and then not the
chance you got you got you gotta go
through tell yourself you're going crazy
you yo yeah
you go you gotta tell your family that
like this is what's up right now it's
not true and they even might look at you
differently as well it's just change
your whole character
literally
and that's the thing like girls even if
they don't go to the police they can
still spread that rumor around campus
yes and girls don't really question each
other on it
yeah like like if if your friend came to
you like i'm not gonna be like oh was it
true like how'd that happen
so it's kind of like
i just believe it straight away yeah
literally
no i i don't always believe it but but
i'm not gonna say like but i'm not gonna
say anything because like what if it did
happen that's that's the problem
i think it's a thin line between like
supporting your friend but you still
have to operate on that facts do you i
mean you need to ask questions to know
you know
it's you're not going to question her
emotions so if if like a female went to
another female she was very emotional
about that that topic
you're not even going to think twice
about questioning it and obviously going
to play in the back of your mind like
did it actually happen but
your first reaction would be like oh
yeah i'm gonna just cater to you like
you can be with me like whatever you
need i've got you
do you think that dna test should be
mandatory i think yes yes yes yes save a
lot of time yes
because boy
hundred percent
i feel like it gets to the point as well
i feel like if it was a lot of a lot of
time wasting that goes on would be quite
short like literally
yeah
for real
because then you get to know sure
it doesn't even have to be mandatory but
i think because a lot of people like
they're so confident or maybe they just
they just don't want to know do you i
mean but like
even if you're just
it's an option at the end of but if it's
like would you do when you if one of
them say yes you have to do it do you i
mean it's not like oh because i said no
like we don't have to do it like what
are you talking about but how does that
work with celebrities though so for
example like no but for example
drake mentioned in one of his songs that
one of some random girl just said oh let
me get a pregnancy test and you're just
wasting the guy's time because multiple
goals would you do the same thing over
and over again trying to
take time and crowd from him so he has
to be certain goals that
that that has to be a limit on the way
you do that to protect certain
individuals from wasting weight
that's true
over and over and over again just ask
your friend
sorry but i don't i don't know you know
why am i doing that for me for me i
think it's a thing where if you're a
celebrity and you know the status you
hold and
everything that comes with it first of
all you should be careful anyway
like whether you chose to become a
celebrity or not like i mean and to it
to me it doesn't whether you're
celebrity or not you're just like
everyone else so if it's mandatory it's
mandatory bro yeah you're still going in
because you're celebrating because
you're gonna get on this flight at this
time and do this isn't that you should
have thought about that before messing
about do you understand that yes that's
if that's what your life holds bro it's
like for us bro we're athletes we play
basketball you're not going to do
anything
out of that line because you know what
you need to do yeah i'm saying so now if
you're messing about and stuff and now
people are telling you to do this test
and do that yeah you got to do it bro
whether you whether you're athlete not
actually a celebrity or not bro you have
to do it
yeah i guess so because it it may waste
time but at least you're certain and you
know yeah
[Music]
knowing that this is 100
then oh just skip it and now i don't
know what sports but what if you've
never met a girl before and she just
made it up then then obviously like
people you look into stuff like that and
it's like bro like i don't even know who
you are yeah i'm saying that that's
yeah dna tests have to be done still no
it's kind of hard to know like if you
have a kid or responsibility out there
and if you're able to actually cater to
that if you can't and you don't know
then that just makes your life ten times
harder because you're thinking about
that every day we're talking about the
story bro
if it's mandatory turn the girl's gonna
waste her time literally they're just
wasting her their own time because if
she knows that right at the end of this
i'm or at some point we need to do the
test and it's it's not true yeah they're
not gonna pick on drake all of a sudden
out of the blue just to say
and we've never even seen each other in
person in our lives because now
when it gets to it
she just found out how deep it is what's
the point of that it was the sun goes on
the cloud though like people will talk
about for example that some girls ask
you for a pregnancy test
and like they'll get like a little
publicity and some girls just like
demons like that
but that's the thing though um obviously
there was a time where like there was a
time where i think i don't i think it
was little dirk apparently oh she was
messing around with someone else and
then there was a kid that looked exactly
like little dirk it's a thing where we
don't know what's going on what they do
so because things like that get
publicized here like gets baited out
it's just straight that's just cloud
like stuff like that just clap because
maybe yeah cool he did have a kid back
then
and
the baby mum and dad already know
because you don't know nothing can
people want clout now all of a sudden
he's jumping on 2022 you're saying that
oh yeah little dirk has a new kid and
she's he's cheating on india
come on bro like that's just
time-wasting do you get
like but people want to just
see people fail and stuff like that
that's what i'm saying like you have a
name for yourself and everyone's like oh
really
you know what i mean oh 10 years ago you
did this to me
it's just long like why why would you
want to do that to someone yeah people
don't want to see like
you don't want to honestly and it's sad
though don't you think yeah it's just
the way our society our generation is
coming because everybody just wants
certain things and some people want what
they can't have so they'll do anything
in their power to tear that down and it
makes no sense because there's no like
there's no glory at the end of the day
for you